♪ ♪ ♪
- Ah! Joyce, elle aimait ça
jouer dans les cheveux
de sa fille.
- Et parfois, quand elle me
brossait, ça faisait du bien.
- Est-ce que je suis devenu un
petit peu bon ou c'est pareil?
- C'est pareil.
(rires)
- Les rires ont pris du temps
avan r r revenir dans
cette maison de Manawan.
Certains gestes, coiffer
les cheveux de Jessica ou faire
leerereron de Carol Junior,
sont même devenus le nouveau
quotidien pour ce père de sept
enfants et aussi grand-père.
CAROL DUBÉ,
conjoint de Joyce Echaquan
- Ça a complètement perturbé
notre vie, même les enfants.
Je me suis découvert que
j'avais d'autres petits talents
comme les tâches ménagères,
les coiffures des filles,
la cuisine. J'apprends encore.
- À l'approche de Noël,
le sapin est prêt. Il porte
la couleur mauve, celle qui
symbolise la femme dont
Carol Dubé est tombé amoureux
au premier regard.
Une femme présente à traversdeds
la maison, mais si absente.
L'année 2020 avait pourtant bien
commencé pour ce couple à la vie
simple, ensemble pendant 23
- On n'était pas le couple
parfait, t'sais... on a eu
des mauvaises années, mais on a
fini sur une très belle année,
malgré cet événement-là.
On avait eu une naissance,
j'avais fait ma demande,
on est devenus grands-parents.
- Cette bague de mariage,
avece e e e e Carol Dubé joue
sans arrêt dès que l'émotion
le submerge, Joyce ne lui aura
jamais passée au doigt.
- On s'est pas rendu là.
- Le 28 septembre 2020, il est
dans sa cuisine en train de
faire le ménage. Thomas, 17 ans,
surgit, complètement bouleversé.
- Je l'ai vu descendre en bas
en courant, puis il m'appe
- Dans la maison?
- Oui. "Papa! Papa!" Il était
tout inquiet, t'sais. "Il faut
que tu vois ça, c'est mama
- Ce que lui montre Thomas,
c'est cette vidéo et une autrepe
en train de prier à voix basse
près de Joyce Echaquan,
inerte, au CISSS de Lanaudière.
Une vidéo frappée
un interdit de publication.
- J'ai tout de suite su que
c'était fini. Je suis tombé ici,
à genoux.
- Depuis plus d'un an,
la vie de Carol Dubé, ce sont
les montagnes russes d'émotion.
Poliment, il répond toujours
en premier qu'il va bien
et pourtant...
- Je ne vais pas bien.
Je suis très, très fatigué
aussi. Comme... je me sens
comme une petite goutte d'eau
dans le désert.
C'est des cadeaux que
je reçois des artistes.
- Seul, mais aussi de
son propre aveu, bien entouré.
Carol Dubé a reçu tellement
de messages de soutien,
des cadeaux aussi
ces portraits car, malgré lui,
Carol Dubé est devenu
le porte-parole d'une cause.
- Elle a voulu dénoncer
qu'est-ce que... qu'est-ce
que... qu'est-ce que
les racisés vivent.
Il était trop silencieux,lelele.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Près du cimetière où repose
Joyce Echaquan, le site
de ressourcement Mirerimowin.
Dans le chapitouane où
la chaleur du feu et l'odeur
du sapinage offrent un certain
réconfort, Carol, entouré
de deux proches, prend une pause
dans ce tourbillon médiatique,
politique de vie.
Il semble parfois à bout de
souffle, mais il se relève avec
en tête une mission à accomplir.
- Je dois continuer à porter
la voix de Joyce, jusqu'à
la fin de ma vie s'il le faut,
pour pas qu'elle tombe dans
l'oubli. Il faut que sa mort
serve... pas sa mort,
mais il faut que son sacrifice
serve à quelque chose.
Elle l'a payé de sa vie.
C'est quelque chose
d'irremplaçable.
- Alors, quand l'émotion
le submerge, il la déverse
en mots dans un carnet intime,
parfois aussi sur Facebook.
- Quand ils t'ont fermé
les yeux, tu nous as ouvert
"nos miennes".
On a tous prié Dieu,
avec toute la nation humaine.
Ensemble, on a marché.
Merci, Joyce, de ton action.